medical workers tell CBS News they're
worried they can't fight the coronavirus
safely right now there's a shortage of
many essential supplies some health care
workers have already been infected
including at least two doctors who are
now in critical condition we spoke to
some doctors fighting the disease on the
frontlines I think we forget that
physicians and nurses and health care
professionals are human too we walk to
the bedside like we always do but now we
are knowing yet we are not protected and
we're facing our own death I'll be
honest we cry about this right where
we're concerned we're scared but we know
what we have to do and we want to be a
part of the solution the fact that we
don't have the right protective gear to
handle these patients makes me know that
I am at risk and I know this because I
do respect the virus I respect the
disease but I also respect my colleagues
and I see that my colleagues are getting
ill and there too right now that are on
ventilator support that makes me very
very worried especially because I have a
family just like they do we have to get
personal protective equipment because
we're gonna lose our workforce if we
don't and our workforce is going to
expose everyone who comes in because
we'll have it and we'll spread it before
we know we have it it's scary
you're afraid we're not doing enough at
work for your patients and then some and
then you feel that you come home and you
haven't done enough at home we're all
experiencing this fear the patients we
want to protect our children but we
don't have the support we don't have the
means we don't have the resources and so
this is our help two of the most
precious human beings in my life my
mother-in-law and my son may also face
potentially life-threatening
consequences because of my decision to
stay at my post to stand on that wall
and protect my patients to the best of
my ability you know as a parent it's
such a struggle to reconcile
my professional duties and obligations
with the fact that those very duties and
obligations could hurt him
boy that was very powerful or dr. Terra
new ruler joins us now with more on this
story
you know terror it's so hard to hear the
doctors say that they're scared and that
they're afraid we all understand that
feeling but it's very unsettling you've
been talking to doctors what are they
saying to you about their experiences
I mean Gail this was just the tip of the
iceberg of the overwhelming response
that we got and it really as a colleague
it was heartbreaking to hear these are
individuals who sacrifice their life for
others they take an oath and they're
telling me that they feel like they're
in a war and they don't have the armor
they need they are using words like
scared in despair powerless like their
sacrificial lambs
and essentially they're screaming out to
be heard and to be helped one of the
biggest issues you heard was the lack of
personal protective equipment they don't
have it they're being asked to reuse
things use them all day they're going
out on their own spending their own
money to find it you know somebody said
it's like being a fireman and asked and
running into a burning building with
flip-flops and a bikini on this is how
they feel they need help another issue
is that they are afraid for their own
health for their family's health saying
I signed up for this job my family did
not sign up to take this risk they're
building makeshift places to stay at
home in the garage they don't infect
their family so here are people who are
physically and psychologically on the
frontlines who are coming home and can't
even get that loving support from their
family because they can't touch them
they're saying that they are being asked
to continue to do elective surgical
cases which the government has come out
and said we really should be avoiding
and many of the doctors who themselves
are either pregnant or
immune-compromised have not received
guidance about whether they should
really still be working in the work
force it's a big big crisis right now
Tara the the American Medical
Association in a letter to the vice
president said ask for something akin to
a
hatton project kind of programmed to
expand manufacturing capacity so we
could produce the supplies that the
doctors need but also there's an issue
of training or is our our medical staff
basically trained to deal with something
like this well I don't know that we're
psychologically trained and we may see
those effects down the line but we know
how to take care of patients I don't
think the training is the issue the
issue is that we don't have the supplies
and we're going to lose our workforce as
you heard you know if our health care
providers start to go down start to get
sick who is going to take care of the
rest of us we know that our health care
providers are now being self quarantined
many are being isolated many are having
to stay home to take care of their own
kids who are out of school and so we
really need a plan in place and and it's
a big systemic issue too you know the
more patients we're getting in the ICU
beds that were either ruling in or out
for colvett or treating we're not able
to take care of patients with other
critical illnesses so this is a big big
issue for the whole system yes a doctor
knew really quickly one last question
here we've been talking about the number
of hospital beds if those are increase
do we have the workforce to staff them
well that's exactly what we were just
saying I think it remains to be seen I
think if we don't protect our health
care practitioners on the front line and
I want to be clear this isn't just
doctors this is nurses nurse
practitioners pas
if we do not give them the proper
protective equipment we will lose them
alright doctor and that will be our
fault there'll be a tragedy and a
tragedy we hope we can avoid dr. Narula
thank you very much